[موسيقى]
هناك العشرات بل والمئات تحت الانقاض
في الرابع والخامس من فبراير من العام
دخلت مناطق الشمال السوري منخفضا جويا
شديد البروده الثلوج الغزيره فاقمت من
معاناه النازحين فاللون الابيض الذي يبعث
بلوحه طبيعيه خلابه لم يكن يحمل المعاني
ذاتها في مخيله السوريين فهو لم يزل
الماساه الا ماساه بعدما اغلقت الطرقات
وانهارت الخيام الرثه فوق رؤوس قاتلها
[موسيقى]
طب ما عنا ولا عود حطب هل كان يروح يجيب
له حطب من الجبل بطل يحسن يمشي
شماليه هذا المشهد قليلا تحديدا في الجنوب
التركي تسبب تدهور الاحوال الجويه في
الغاء شركه الخطوط الجويه التركيه لمئتين
واربعين رحله محذره من الغاء جميع الرحلات
فيما كان سكان المنطقه يتهياون للمنخفض
الجوي
باغتت الارض الجميله
في ولايه غازي عنتاب جنوب تركيا مدينه
تشهد على اكبر كارثه عاشتها البلاد في
تاريخها الحديث نحن الان في مدينه كهرمان
مرعش وهي اكثر المدن تضررا في البلاد
نتيجه الزلزال تعد مدينه منكوبه كما
وصفتها السلطات في هذه الولايه التركيه
اديمون تركزت معموديه الدم والموت والدمار
في التغطيات الاعلاميه عن الفترات السابقه
المدينه المنكوبه بكل مال هذه الكلمه من
معنى عندما وصلتها بعد ايام من حدوث
الزلزال لم استطع استيعاب ما رايته خصوصا
انني زرتها مرارا خلال السنوات الماضيه
هنا
الصور والحرب والدمار والرصاص منذ عقود
عديده ولكن الموت عاد بصوره اخرى
180 ثانيه قد تمر في حياه الكثيرين دون
اكتراث لكنها لدى سكان سوريا وتركيا غيرت
الكثير
[موسيقى]
اجا شاب من جيراننا لعندي واخذنا
قلت الحمد لله توفت
قلت له انا
عند الرابعه وسبعه عشره دقيقه من فجر
الاثنين السادس من فبراير
تغيرت وجهات مدن باكملها شوارع وطرقات
اضحت من الماضي جغرافيه منطقه
انقلبت راسا على عقب
كانك فريق عمن عم نشتغل اثناء العاصفه
الثلجيه لمساعده العائلات لو توزيع مواد
تدفئه وكنا عم ننقل عائلات من خيم لبيوت
ضمن حمله حتى اخر خيمه
وفجاه حصل زلزال طبعا جندير للاسف في
الوقت الحالي هي مدينه المنكوبه بسبب دمار
الهائل في ابنيه كتير تدمرت حتى حارات كان
تدمرت نسعى الفرق من الدفاع المدني محاوله
انه مساعده المدنيين
نزل حيطان علينا طالعت عيالي واولادي
الحمد لله رب العالمين
اجيت على بيت اخوي لقيت البنايه كلها
تم استقبال عدد كبير من المرضى الزلزال
حدث بوقت
متاخر معظم الناس في بيوتها
على مدار القرن قد تكون هذه اللقطات لاثار
الزلزال المدمر الذي بلغت قوته سبع درجات
وسبعه اعشار الدرجه تجسيدا لاسوء كارثه
انسانيه تعيشها المنطقه
علينا البنايه كلها اربع طوابع
طلعنا طلعونا العالم
سبحان الله كنا فايقين اثناء
ارضيه خفيفه يعني فتكرناها عاديه بتصير
يعني صدف فصارت تقوى كل ما يعني انها تقوى
وصار البيت يرج مضبوط ساعه قليله انجلى
خلالها الظلام ومعها بدات خيوط الدمار
تتكشف اعداد الضحايا تضاعفت سجلت في
البدايه المئات لكن سرعان ما انتقلت
الاحصاءات الى الالاف ومن ثم الى عشرات
الالاف
الزلزال شيء جديد علينا مالنا مدربين على
هيك شيء
مدربين على كتير كوارث صارت عنا ونقصف
وطيران وتفجيرات ولو انقذت شخص واحد من
تحت الانقاض عايش فهذا انجاز كثير عظيم
انا
هذا الشارع تغيرت معالمه بالكامل وكما
تشاهدون قوه الزلزال كيف اثرت على هذا
الشارع وهذه وهذا الدمار الكبير
حجم ضحايا الزلزال فاقد تقديرات كذلك فاق
قدرات السلطات ففي احيان كثيره لم يكن
هناك مجال للتعرف الى هويه القتلى حرمت
الكارثه الاقرباء من لحظات وداعي ذويهم
بعدما دفنوا في مقابر جماعيه استبدلت فيها
الاسماء بالارقام
لا زلنا في قهرمان مرعش تحديدا قرب عدسه
احد المصورين التي تركزت على رجل يتمسك
بيد ابنته التي فارقت الحياه وصل الاب
جلسته محدقا في الدمار لساعات طويله لا
يابه لما يدور من حوله سوى انامل ابنته
اخويه شفناه على البرنده شفته طالع نصه
لبره عرفناه توفى
عنده بنت عمرها توفى عندي ولد عمره 13 سنه
14 سنه
بعد ساعه
ضرب بعض ظهره
وعندي بنت طلعت الحمد لله بعد اربعه ايام
طلعت
بس
مجرد وصول الى مكان
الزلزال مجرد ما يشوفوني اهالي الناس اللي
تحت الانقاذ بشوفونا انه هذا الشخص البطل
الخارق اللي بده يطالع اطفالنا من تحت بدي
طالع زوجتي من تحت ممكن انه هذا الشخص اجا
فخلص انا عندي امل انه يطالع لابني عايش
وقتها كان كتير برد وثلج
طلعت انا انا وجارتي
الله يرحمه هي سهرت عندي لوقت متاخر
بعدين قمت رحنا كبين
قمت رحنا كبينا الصوبه ورجعت
بس بينيتهم صبي مات
الاكبر منها بسنتين عمره 14 سنه
قال له نفسي
يشيل عروسة وتشاهد تشاهد بصوت عالي
وتوفى
انا جيت بدي تفوت على اولادي ما احسنت مو
انطعجت البنايه الباب الحديد
شلفنا على الدرج
قلبت البنايه
بس نحن لضعف الامكانيات اللي كانت وحتى
بناء وصلنا له بعد اربعين ساعه خمسين ساعه
نحن كان في عنا حماس وكان في عنا امل مع
انه تعبنا بس ووصلنا ساعات الليل مع
النهار تخلص
ساعات النهار نشغل بلجكتورات نكمل شغل بس
المواد الموجوده عنا ما تساعدنا فنضطر
نشيل الانقاذ بطريقه
يعني نحاول انه بقدر الامكان بسرعه
بس هذا الشيء ما ساعدنا كتير لاني كانت
الامكانيات كتير ضعيفه
اسر بالكامل غابه اثرها ولم يبقى من
ابنائها شخص وحيد قد يخلد ذكراها اسره
اخرى نجت طفلتها التي انتظرت امها قدومها
منذ اشهر لتولد تحت انقاذ بيتها المنهار
الرضيعه عفراء ابصرت النور بين الركام في
الوقت الذي فارقت والدتها الحياه وقف
الباجر احفر نادون الشباب قالوا لي في
حرمه هون اذا تعرفها تعال شوفها اجيت
لعندها طلعت ام ردينه وانا عم احفر سمعت
صوت الطفله تصيح فقلت لهم ابو ردينه من
فرحته قلت لهم ابو ردينه عايش عايش وقت
شلت تراب عنها طلعت البنت امها والدته شلت
الحبل هذا تبع السره قطعته فقلت انا ابو
ردينه وعيلته الله يرحمه فانقض البنت هاي
يظل ذكره يعني واسعى فتاه على المشفى
جيهان بعفرين حاولنا كتير قليل اول شيء
طلعنا امه الله يرحمها وطلعنا اخته لجين
كمان الله يرحمها واخوه احمد كمان الله
يرحمه اخويا يزن الكبير كمان الله يرحمه
اول يوم ثاني يوم
اخذناهم على جبل
[موسيقى]
هنا رضيع يبلغ من العمر شهرين يخرج حيا
وسط ذهول كل من كان يتابع المشهد
وهذه الطفله شام محمد وصلت صمودها تحت
الانقاض لاربعين ساعه كما عصير
وكل شيء
تحدي هاي اللحظه انا ماني قادر اوقف قدام
وشوف وضعها لانه وضعها
بالنسبه للهرس
صعب كتير تحتاج شديده
وصراحه ما بدي انهار قدام شام تحت حافز هي
نفس القوه ونفس
الطاقه اللي كانت موجوده فيها اطفال بحاله
صدمه ما ممكن حدا يتخيلها حالات البتر
حالات الهرس حالات الكسور
القطاع الطبي يعني تنفذ بالكامل
الممرضين مع بلحقوا كانوا الاطفال
والحالات ممرات المشفى قطع الكهرباء ما في
المشافي صرنا ندعم المشافي بالمازوت يعني
كل شيء الكوارث كلها
اجت مع بعضها هنا وقف الشقيق على الردم
يصرخ باعلى صوته لشقيقه عله يسمع صوته
فيخرجه من تحت الانقاذ هنا جلست الخالات
والعمات والجدات لايام عديده وهن ينتظرن
الاطفال الصغار تفرقت العائلات هنا مشت
الجنائز بالطوابير الى المدافن التي كتبت
بالاسماء للمعروفات والتي دونت بالارقام
للمجهوله
الان يستعدون يستعدون الكل يستعد عائشه
طفله تبلغ من العمر سبعه اعوام خاضت صراعا
طويلا لمده سته ايام وسط امل وخوف اطبق
على المكان لساعات طويله
عائشه الان تخرج بعد ولاده عسيره وولاده
قيصريه
عايش تخرج من رحم الركام
كل سكان المدينه او من بقي منهم على قيد
الحياه يعيشون الان في خيام واماكن ايواء
مؤقته يضاف اليهم الاف اللاجئين السوريين
الذين كانوا يعيشون هنا منذ سنوات عديده
قصص ماساويه كثيره سمعناها سواء من
الاتراك او من اللاجئين السوريين لكن تبقى
قصص اللاجئين السوريين الاكثر ايلاما على
سبيل المثال ابو الفضل وهو لاجئ سوري كان
يعيش هنا في اصلاحيه فقدت تسعه من افراد
عائلته اطفاله الثلاثه اضافه الى شقيقه
وزوجته واطفالهما ايضا شقيقته وزوجها
واطفالهما
وكارست الزلزال يعني لا تشبه اي كارثه نحن
نعرف انه ممكن انهدم مبنى او ينقصها بمبنى
ويكون في عائله وعائلتين تحت الانقاذ لانه
مئات المباني مره وحده خلال 40 ثانيه
يصيروا الناس من الاف تحت الانقاض
ان المشافي تطلع عن الخدمه او انه ما في
كهرباء بالمشافي بلحظه معينه وكل الناس
لازم تروح على المشافي بهاللحظه الاف
الجرحى
زميلاتي صارت تبكي قلت لها لا ما وقعت
بدنا نحن بدنا نكون قوايا مشان هالمرضى
اللي بدهم يجوا مشان انه نحسن يعني نقدم
لهم اكبر شيء منطقتنا ونعالجه القدر
الامكان
يمكن نقل الدمار والدموع واعداد القتلى
والجرحى والناجين لكن وحدها رائحه الموت
على امتداد 10 ولايات لا يمكن نقلها
بعد نحو اسبوعين من زلزال السادس من
فبراير توقفت جهود البحث عن ناجين في عدد
من المحافظات
فرع الدفاع المدني كانت موجوده وحتى
المهندسين اللي كانوا موجودين منعوني انه
ادخل على انه هذا الشيء خطر كتير
وخلص يعني بعد مرور كل هاي الساعات مضى
انت بتقدر تخاطر بحياتك كرمال شخص متوفي
يعني
هذا الشيء كتير حس بقلبي وانقهرت
لبنتك لماما
واركدنا كلياتنا على الدور واللهم عافينا
وهبط فينا
البنايه
بنتي الله يرحمها
[موسيقى]
الستاره لم يكن قد اصدل بعد على الماسى
ففي العشرين من فبراير زلزال جديد داهم
ولايه هاتاي التركيه بقوه ست درجات واربعه
اعشار الدرجه تاركا خلفه عشرات القتلى
والمصابين عم مقام من جراح لم تندمي بعد
من تبعات زلزالي السادس من فبراير
ثلاثه ايام عمرها خمس سنين
تقول له
[موسيقى]
السندويشه بطاطا
عند الدور كله
اربعه ايام خمسه ايام
انهزمنا من سوريا مشان القصف
جينا لهون سبحان الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
هالماسات لن تتوقف بالخصوص عند السوريين
الاتراك كذلك نالوا قسطا وافرا
من هذا الزلزال لكن
القصص التي ارعبت العالم كلها تقريبا
من بقي حيا من السكان لم يكن مصيرهم اقل
ماساويه من ضحايا الزلزال لتصل توابع
الزلزال الى مدن لم يمسسها حالات النزوح
الواسعه بدت الاكبر من نوعها منذ الحرب
السوريه نازحون الطر للاستقرار عند
الولايات القريبه خارج نطاق المناطق
المنكوبه مثل قيصري ومرسين فيما اكمل
باقون الطريق الى اسطنبول وازمير وانقره